50 minutes left of this two hour event
so you're welcome to jump in maybe we'll
end up getting paired up in this 10-0
all right
so round one of this late join
let's try what move
i'll go with the e4
okay sicilian land
i've been playing around with this 92
move
far from
uh
an expert on this variation i don't know
all the details the the main thing that
sticks out to me is that this guy
remains
uh free to move
so all right well i'm immediately drawn
to this hole on d5 so
even even knight here could be a move
i'll go with this one
so i'm really keying in on a d5
and
i can't play d4
so let's go with d3
i would really like to have this in
there
but i think to to move the knight
it's a little bit clumsy he's not the
knight's not going to be so great on g3
so
i'm going to go with what
a setup that i initially
was thinking of
i was initially thinking of going with
this kind of setup before this committal
move was in there and d5 was a whole
so i'll i'll still carry on with
this this plan to fianchetto and have my
my bad bishop inside the chain
and directed on the
long diagonal
observes d5 i think this was worth
considering
because now
um
i'm not sure how great a
roll
uh the d pawn is is going is playing
here
uh one of one of the things i i think
about here is because because of this
hole
on d5 and there's a pawn right here
if i if i could maintain control over
this
i'm really limiting the strength of the
d6 pawn
all right so
probably just castle
i am a little
trying to figure out what what might be
the idea here is the bishop intending to
get on this diagonal
or this kind of stuff to trade my light
square bishop
so if i castle queen c8
i'm going to go with this move first
and
yeah i'm just going to go with h3 first
i want to
i guess i want to gather a little bit
more information
before i make my decision to castle okay
so now i feel much more comfortable
castling queen c8
is really not a problem king h2
snug like a bug in a rug somebody was
just pointing that out
in the chat i'm not
i'm not saying that phrase enough they
said so there you go
he would be snug like a bug in a rug on
h2 nice and cozy
so from here
no rooks are playing we have to get an
open file and this is the only one that
really
can be opened up
one little check here before i even
touch this guy
open diagonal
these guys gonna hurt me
i don't think so
no checks
in the position for either side
yet
so if
okay that's interesting what's what's
the deal there
i have enough support over e4
this diagonal is being opened up
i could bypass if i really wanted to
play d4
i think i'm i think i may want to play
d4 instead of winning this pawn
intensifies the pressure here i think it
i think it forces black to give up their
strong e5 pawn when playing d4 there is
something i gained with d4
as as
i could win a pawn like this i'm taking
away from the center but i believe there
is benefit in this advance
i think it's pretty intolerable as
otherwise i maybe i played d5 and
squashed this guy
after this it's this guy's close to
being trapped would be trapped
bishop b5a4
so
let me just kind of scan for another
moment or two
d4 or chop
[Music]
i'm gonna go with d4
um
now let's win the pawn
all right so something that was running
is running through my mind a little bit
and uh i have to be a little bit careful
i i don't know
my opponent's
tuning in yeah this check
this check i did see
um
i have to be a little careful
yeah let me
i'm gonna play here
i'm not gonna go with the
snug like a bug in a rug
square
yeah
this move i wasn't so much concerned
about i wanted to stay off of h2 because
i thought h5 and then this idea of
knight g form with check might be in the
air as it stands now my knight is
offsetting their knight on h5
and this isn't really a piece that can
be disrupted
so i still have some work to do here i
want to get my bishop on e3
so
let's start with queen here
and i may want to also
play b3 first
i don't think i really want to give up
my b pawn let's start with this
now it's true the knight could play to
c5 but then i have this my opponent is
playing very fast
so
to keep this in mind
i am up upon
castled
i need one bishop move to be
connected with these guys
i have some good coordination
that move feels like it's somewhat of a
passing move
i'll flick in this move a4
to not even allow this
break
as i
i see it right now that the only open
file is going to be on the f file
and so
i don't want additional files to open up
if i could keep it
such that there's
only this f file that's going to be
opened and i control it
i think that's only benefiting me
okay queen there feels like she's asking
for trouble
no
it certainly feels like she's asking for
trouble
there
it feels a little weird but i'm gonna
play this one
i have something up my sleeve
do you see my threat
okay
was i was preparing to play queen knight
here and then bishop here
can i still do that
not exactly
i have to watch out for this uh e4 pawn
there
striking at it three times
if they had castled knight here and
after capture then the queen queen was
going to be dead after bishop a3
i think it's now time to drop that
knight into d5
maybe my pawns get straightened out
they do
and from here
what i'm going to do is challenge their
best piece
their night
my knight on e2 isn't the brightest
piece around
offset by this this pawn on
e5
okay i'm going to take here this this
they have pressure here but they have to
take back here well they're not taken
back there though
so that's uh
i get to save this piece
i'm up a clear night now they could grab
here but um
they do they're playing fast man they're
playing fast
all right let's open up this f file
and
what's the way what is the way here
i guess we'll take another pawn
i'm looking at rook b1 stuff but
i i really want to get at their king
still in the center 27 moves in no
castles
look there
oh i have i have rook takes here
this is a sneaky move
that's a sneaky one
uh so i had that on the previous move
right
unprotected pieces is the problem
can you spot the unprotected piece
got knight there's the follow-up winning
the queen
i'll take
and i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with this
move
i do have a check
but i'm getting the queens off
they might have something where they
counter-attack my rook and this guy
could go into pac-man mode
we shall see
all right so
a knight versus pawn imbalance
and
i guess we could
yeah yeah why not let's grab a pawn
move forward i got f1 covered
no great entry points
i just want to be a simplifying machine
all even exchanges are cool with me
so that's a start
end game active king
and let's work on the coordination a
little bit
but this guy in a secure square
could go here and then they're all
coordinated well maybe
tuck the king in
let's start with this one
or not
yeah let's let's start with that one
there is this and i cannot take
threatening the b7 pawn
is also threatening to
simply uh go to b7
with the fork
let's go here
also i have back rank mates
possibly
keep moving forward
this is covered
many times
so
i could get out of this pin
threatening this
and that
chop here
and i don't have to take back that's
going to be me
all right
round one in the books of this
tournament
you